So Rich mentioned personas and use cases as a
way to understand our users attributes and their behaviors.
>> Yeah, and remember we asked you to come up with a, three features for pizza
application for entry. And we have a situation
where you came up with a feature list, and.
>> Yeah.
>> And we each came up with a different one,.
And we had gone over two options, which is to combine
the features or just pick one of our feature sets.
But those are actually both not the right thing to do.
>> The way
we really should have started was, to start with personas and
use cases. Because we could have debated and talked about features
all day. Everybody had really great ideas of features, but if
we had started with personas and use cases, we would have
come up with very different feature lists. A persona is a
proxy for a group of actual users of a product, for
whom the UX is going to be optimized. A use case
is the scenario of how, when, and where a persona will
use your product to accomplish a task.